i apologize for running a little bit
behind today because i was really busy
playing with a certain figure finally
steve
i just want i just want to point out
just because i forgot to have it during
the last interview doesn't mean i didn't
have it
exactly i feel like
just throwing that out there all right
so um by the way this hot toys
sideshow figure is is really effing cool
i don't know if you've actually seen it
it's kind of crazy actually i don't like
how much it looks like me actually when
we finally got it back i was like that's
a little too close people could stick
pins in that and actually probably
affect me
um you are right uh into why i get to
talk to you today
uh how many people i know you're
involved in a lot of cool stuff
but did you find that more people than
like anything else
any other project you've worked on
wanted to visit you on the set of this
movie
oh of course you know you have lebron
fans you have looney tunes fans you just
yeah it's it was a huge undertaking
and uh every day we were you know kind
of
anticipating what it would be like when
we finally got to see it i still
haven't seen it i'm going to see it at
the premiere next week for the first
time so i i hope people dig it and i
hope it comes off
uh you were really good in this movie uh
man i wanted to talk about some of the
stuff in the film but i'll pass that
did you take true or false did you take
this movie
uh just to get better seats at lakers
games um
no but true is a better story so yeah
true got it did you uh lebron has some
amazing sneakers
and he puts out a lot of sneakers uh did
you get to walk away from this shoot
with any sneakers
i actually did he actually gave me a
pair of his sneakers uh
which are massive uh and i have them on
my counter at home
are they like are they like shoes he was
wearing that day or like game
like what what kind of shoes no i did
they were just shoes that he just gifted
me at the end
um that yeah he wasn't wearing no he
just gave me some a pair of shoes brand
new pristine beautiful perfect shoes
is that the kind of thing though listen
i know you must own cool stuff but is
that the kind of thing that you want to
frame and put on the wall
or you know what i mean yeah no it's
it's honestly the kind of thing that
you know you keep and then you go okay
what am i actually gonna do with this
they're cool and the moment the exchange
was cool the gift of them was cool but
then you have them you're like
i guess they just live up there now i
uh yeah so many i i don't know what i
would do with them
i love i love learning about behind the
scenes when you're making something so
maybe what might surprise people to
learn about the making of this film on
your end
um i don't know it was just tedious i
think people see the end product
uh of a movie like this especially and
don't realize how much of that is done
in post
how much of that is done after the
filming is already done you know we're
in these cgi
worlds we have green screen all over the
place we're looking at an x to be you
know where bugs bunny is or a cardboard
cut out of daffy duck or something and
a lot of the sound comes in afterwards
and a lot of the environment that you
see around us
is is all put in uh after we're finished
with it
so the magic of it all coming together
is it's it's
as exciting to us i think as it is uh
people seeing the movie because we were
there and didn't see any of that stuff
uh before i run out of time with you as
you can imagine by looking the stuff
behind me i'm kind of a marvel fan
um i'm very curious about armor wars
right so they announce it what what what
do you know
when do you start filming what can you
tease people uh
all i know is that we're gonna go into
the room uh in a couple weeks and
actually start trying to break the spine
of the story and figure out
who what when and where for all of it um
it's super super early in the
development stages so i couldn't even
spoil it if i wanted to i don't know
what happens
i'll leave it alone i'll just say nice
to see you good to see you too steve
take care buddy